[Music]
no
i have not tiger daiger
2500 from turkey
they're gonna play f3 and then h4
wow wow
okay okay
okay let's
challenge accepted
if i've ever had the
the motivation to just
like usually in these
these events i just want to play a good
game
and hopefully try and be instructive as
well
but after this opening my motivation is
just to crush this guy
mercilessly
and that's why i'm playing really
aggressively
just the the nerve
he does have courage though
um what did i do what did i do
now i have to exchange queens because if
also bishop d4
c3 i've had to exchange queens there as
well
so now it's just going to be some
[ __ ] precise win
who wants that
nobody's here to see that
when you play the uh i don't know
accelerated bum cloud or whatever you
want to call it
you want to see blood not this it's just
a spectacular failure on my part
i even gave him some
i know some kind of compensation here
in the form of bishop pair obviously
it's not even
[Music]
close to being enough
nevertheless this was disappointing
bishop h6 wow
that is a sick move
okay so he took i thought his idea was
to go bishop e2 there
now it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
okay rook h1 that's nice but it doesn't
matter
i do lose one of my two extra pawns but
i
i will end up with two protected passers
and um and an easy win
didn't want to go g5 yet not to allow
rook to
[Music]
uh to to h7 now he does have rook h7
uh h8 and rook b8
okay didn't say that
what an annoying dude
just uh
killed my spirit right there and there
right there and then
okay i just need to be sure
to make sure that i'm at least
sort of fast and now i'm winning
okay that's rookie a8 not to lose
another pawn but
i'm pleased i'm winning the game
very easily
he may as well resign here like you and
f3 h4 king f2
and actually made some sort of game of
it
your job isn't done here now mister
don't waste any more
time from people who who also want to
also want to get the chance to play
you got your meme
and he resigns probably probably
listening in
that was um that was at least respectful
i got to give him props though he played
he played well after after the
meemish opening